bonjour à tous de temps le conducteur et
le conducteur oui mais oui voilà donc
aux adducteurs voilà vous avez le
programme
voilà le programme bras le proposer
toutes les missions avec les minutage
donc oui on trouve sur avec les
militants j'ai pris alors la tâche est
de suivre correctement moi je suis déjà
très très très très bien nous allons
voir
scooby doo et est mort a doucement je
n'étais pas demander d'annoncer scooby
doo
le nom choisi de soizic regarde c'est
bien ce qui est écrit ici à cet endroit
là pourquoi moi je pourrais pas
l'annoncer scooby doo
parce que jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est moi
qui présente cette émission quoi nous on
ne peut rien dire alors si tu fais moi
je dis scooby doo
le chien le plus malin de tous les
chiens
voilà non non non non non nous voulons
présenter scooby doo et nous voulons
présenter broc et schnock et nous
voulons participer activement à cette
émission
nous voulons des responsabilités voilà
écoutez vous avez déjà un conducteur où
tout est inscrit 1
alors si vous voulez éventuellement
vache peut vous donner quelques
responsabilités en comble oui attendez
que je réfléchisse comme par exemple pas
tenez je vous propose la distribution
des petits pains chauds les rues les
plus part de colas rouges ont croqué par
leur nom mais si c'est écrit mais s'est
écrite mais pas pour maintenant
maintenant regardez maintenant ils
étaient serez inscrit
scooby doo le titre c'est le gorille au
cinéma alors regardons d'abord scooby
doo les petits pains au chocolat plus
tard corry